The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: This afternoon I
talked a bit about Russian film
and suggested that
among other things
that the cultural environment in
which the Russian film emerged
was an environment of revolution
and of ideological turmoil.
And we could say,
therefore, in some degree,
if Russian film served
revolutionary ideals
and the ideology
of the Bolsheviks,
the German film had its own sort
of boss, its own authorities
that it was following.
But it was not in a narrow
sense political or ideological
as the Russian example was.
But it was something similar.
The German film
I want to suggest
for a good part of
life, a silent film,
was in thrall to
established culture.
It's an example of
the sort of thing
I was saying this afternoon
about the difference
between European cinema
and American cinema.
American cinema grew
up in an atmosphere
of wild populist
freedom, almost untouched
by the cultural
authorities who mostly
on the east coast of
the country dominated
literature, drama,
and so forth-- music.
In contrast, in
Germany, the film
grew up in the cultural
centers of the society,
and the dominant cultural
figures, the major writers,
the major dramatists, the
major poets and musicians,
the established theater
actors and directors
all migrated into the film.
And it gave German film
a tremendous intellectual
ambition and authority from
its various earliest stages,
and I'll show you
some examples of this.
It made the German film,
especially the German film
in the period between the
end of the First World War
and the advent of
sound that sometimes
is called-- I don't know
if this is correct--
but some people call
it the golden age
of German silent film, the
golden age of German film,
because an extraordinary
number of very
important and influential
films were made
in this period, roughly
from about 1916 or '17
through the '20s,
through about 1926
or '27 before the
advent of sound.
And it certainly is a very
distinctive and influential
moment in the history
of cinema, but as you
will see in the examples I'm
going to give you, influential
as many of these
films were, they
were influential
in what we might
say-- they were
influential in part
not because they were
wonderful examples
of exploratory
innovative cinema,
but because of the grandeur
or the disturbing authority
of the themes they encompassed.
In other words, the German film,
as I suggested this afternoon,
because it was guided by
cultural authorities who
were adept at earlier
media, at older media,
they already came to the
making of film, of their films,
with high artistic intentions.
I'm not so sure they realized
those intentions, because they
didn't explore the
full nature of film
as much as might have been done.
But they were interesting
and deeply influential films.
And I should also admit
that my perspective
is, perhaps, biased.
There are certainly
many, many people
who have written
magnificently and seriously
on this era of German film,
who would not be negative
as I am about what
I'm calling the sort
of uncinematic or
unvisual qualities of some
of the masterpieces, early
masterpieces in the category.
It's a contested argument, and I
don't want you to simply accept
my word for this.
Take it as a perspective
that could be qualified
or even challenged
by other folks,
and especially by
certain film scholars
who see this moment in
German cinema as a really
fruitful and generative moment.
Much of the basic
understanding that we
have of German silent film
comes from one remarkable book
by a woman named
Lottie Eisner, and I
wanted to mention it here.
I borrowed a tremendous
amount of what
I'm going to say from her book,
learned a great deal from it.
Eisner was a wonderfully
important historical figure,
worked as a film historian and
annotator and film archivist
for a good part of her career.
Some of you who
are film buffs may
know that Wim Wender, as the
great contemporary experimental
German director,
dedicated his film Paris,
Texas to Lottie Eisner.
She worked for a long time
in the French Biblioteque,
the first great archive of
movies in the Western world.
She also wrote
books, separate books
about Murnau and Fritz Lang,
two of the great figures
in this tradition we're looking
at briefly this evening.
And her arguments in
The Haunted Screen
are still widely accepted.
The book focuses on the
Weimar period, the period
before the rise of Hitler,
after the First World War,
in which German culture was an
astonishingly rich, fermenting,
stew of innovation and anxiety.
It's the era of
the great cabarets,
and you will return to this
era in an imaginative way
when you come to see
the film Cabaret later
in the term, which tries
to reimagine that moment.
And it actually
dramatizes the era
in which the German films I'm
talking about this evening
were made.
One way I can begin
to identify or explain
the distinctive qualities
of these German films
is to talk briefly about
the idea of expressionism.
The broad word
expressionism refers
to movement in
modernist art that
involves principles of
distortion and surreal
exaggeration.
So an expressionist work
of art, either a painting
or a poem or a film,
is in some degree
interested in finding
equivalents for the inner life,
dramatizing not the external
world, but the world within us,
and especially the
tormented world within us--
our anxieties, our fears,
our sexual fantasies,
our murderous impulses.
There's a dark, disturbing side
to expressionism, especially
to German expressionism.
There are expressionist artists
who appear in other traditions,
and expressionism is a movement
that goes far beyond Germany.
But one might say that German
expressionism is the expression
of modernism in German culture.
It's almost indistinguishable.
If we talked about
modernism more generally,
we would say that not
every aspect of modernism
involves expressionism.
But in Germany, we would say the
modernist impulse was embodied
in the expressionist tendencies
of the art forms that
appear in that period.
Let me talk a bit about them.
They involve the
external representation
of the inner life, as I've said.
And they're interested,
the expressionists,
in elemental emotions like
fear, love, hatred, anxiety.
They're interested in our
aggressive and appetitive
impulses.
The sources of this
expressionist movement
are in German romanticism.
This is the literary
movement that
gave rise to important
poets and painters
in the earlier part
of the 19th century.
And also in economics, in
the historical realities
of German culture,
because the period we're
talking about when
these films were made,
the Weimar period
was a period of-- was
a unstable and turbulent period.
There were power outages all the
time, for example, frequently,
even in the major
cities like Berlin.
And the visual style
of the expressionists--
there were expressionist
painters, expressionist poets,
expressionist musicians,
expressionist dramatists.
Virtually all the
art forms in Germany
in some degree participated in
this interest in the irrational
and in the hidden and
in the turbulent night
side of our personalities.
And I can, perhaps,
very quickly capture
some of the essence
of this movement
by showing you a couple of
paintings that are examples
of this expressionist movement.
Let me show you one image
first, and then I'll
do a slideshow while
I talk a bit more,
and you can watch the slideshow.
This is a painting by the
German painter Beckmann,
and it's called "The Family."
It sometimes has been used as
the illustration on the cover
of Kafka's The Metamorphosis.
And we might say
incidentally, if you're
looking for examples of what
expressionism would be like,
how many of you have read Kafka?
Only a couple.
OK.
How many of you remember
the first sentence
of The Metamorphosis?
All right.
I'll tell it to you
in some translations.
Gregor Samsa awoke one morning
after a night of uneasy dreams
to find himself transformed
into a gigantic insect.
Maybe the most famous first
sentence in modern literature.
But think about that.
And then the whole
story proceeds
from that shocking
transformation.
So one of the things that's
characteristic of these forms
of expression of are
principles of exaggeration
that take you into surrealism
and into modes of exaggeration
that attempt to illuminate
reality not by giving you
a realistic picture of
it, but by exaggerating
certain elements in reality so
intensely that you understand
them more deeply and fully
than you might have otherwise.
It's important to recognize
that surreal impulses like this
or expressionist
impulses like this
do not mean that the
stories or art forms that
are committed to
these strategies
are unrealistic in
the broadest sense.
That is to say they
still talk about reality.
It's just that the
realities they talk about
do not allow themselves
to be represented
in straightforward ways,
because they're either hidden,
or the intensity
that they represent
is so hidden within us that if
you represent them externally,
you need to exaggerate.
You need to highlight.
You need to enlarge.
So we might think of Kafka
as a literary embodiment
of this principle
of expressionism,
and we might think of
paintings like this
as the painterly
embodiment of it.
And look at this.
We won't have to spend
much time on this,
but look closely at it.
Look at how the whole
family is crammed together
in an incredibly tight space,
the ceiling pressing down
on them.
Look how grotesque
each of them is.
But what's the most obvious
thing about the painting?
Can you see what it looks like?
None of the characters
are looking at each other.
There's no connection
between them.
They're all isolated in
their own little space.
Not only are they physically
grotesque and a little weird,
but they're all caught in their
own narcissistic or, perhaps,
drug-induced stupor.
Calling it "The Family?"
Think of what an unromantic
unsentimental view
of the family this is.
But it's the principles
of distortion
and surreal exaggeration that
you can see in this image
that we might say are
the essence of what
is meant by expressionism.
Do the slideshow now.
While I'm talking, I'll
show you a series of images
by other painters,
and we can put this
on so they'll see what's what.
So just play this,
Kristen, while I continue.
So one of the things that--
so this expressionist movement
was central to all the high arts
of German society at the time.
And it's, therefore,
not an accident,
not at all, not even
remotely an accident
that such energies
would express themselves
in the new medium of
the movies, because so
much of the German
art establishment
was already embracing
principles of this kind.
And some very
remarkable, of course,
and significant,
immensely influential
films grew out of this movement.
They emphasized atmospheric
qualities like lighting and set
design, and they
were interested,
as I've already implied,
in morbid states
and in distortion, in
inner fears and anxieties.
And what one of the things
that the expressionist moment
in German cinema
certainly did was
it tremendously
furthered our sense
of the power of the cinema to
explore human subjectivity.
Even the films that,
for me at least,
looked more like
historical artifacts
than living works of art
have this fascination for us,
for me.
We might also very
quickly acknowledge
how profoundly influential
the movement was.
Can you think-- any
of you know what
famous directors after the--
not even German directors--
are linked repeatedly
with German expressionism,
have connections to them?
One of them is
Alfred Hitchcock, who
actually, his very first
film was a co-production
with German producers.
And he carried it-- if you
think of Hitchcock's work,
Hitchcock carries the some of
the darkness and the distortion
and the interest in our
inner convulsive lives
that is present in
German expressionism.
But there are other
examples as well.
The American gangster
film shows the influence
of German expressionism
very powerfully,
and the great American
director Orson Welles
was steeped in
German expressionism,
and some of his greatest
effects and the atmospheres
of his films could be said
to be a direct outgrowth
of expressionist directing,
of expressionist movies.
So it's a critical
and powerful movement.
So let me now turn to
a couple of examples
to give you a sense in film
of how this expressed itself.
And my first example comes from
the film, the very famous film
directed by Robert Wayne, called
The Cabinet of Dr. Caligari.
It's a story about a murderer,
who when he goes to sleep,
he turns into a
monster, and he wakes up
and he walks around like a
somnambulist ready to kill
people.
And it may be there
were, of course,
lurid stories in
the public press
of these kinds of all the time.
So there may have been, in
the watching of the film,
there may have also been a kind
of [INAUDIBLE] in the audience
of feeling that what they
were watching potentially
was possibly real or
reflected certain forms
of certain possibilities
in reality.
But as you'll see, the film
is tremendously stylized.
It's tremendously
planned in a way.
One of the most interesting
things about the film
is that the sets were
designed and painted
by prominent
expressionist artists,
and then the fact is it
was as much an artwork
as it was a movie.
Let me show you part of it,
and you could see for yourself
the consequences of an
artistic movement that
grows out of traditional
art being transferred
to the movies.
Here's a scene from the film.
Do we have sound?
No sound, I guess.
Sorry.
There would have been music, of
course, and very scary music.
Maybe you can hear some of it.
I think their soundtrack
is also a new one.
It was superimposed and
made for the film later.
But I suppose in a certain way,
this has a kind of interest.
But do you see how static
it is, how uncinematic it
is, how stable the camera
is, how the emphasis is
on-- I don't know.
What could we call it?
On set design, on
surreal angles,
on this strange
form of lighting?
This chiaroscuro black and white
lighting, very great emphasis
on contrast between black
and white, of course,
becomes a trademark element
of expressionistic films
and then is carried over in
many other film traditions,
including the American
tradition called film
noir-- dark film, black film.
So here's this
somnambulist walking over
to the sleeping woman.
We might note parenthetically,
isn't interesting
how long one might say that this
is one of the earliest horror
films?
How long has the
horror film used
as one of its central
elements violence
against women, and especially
sexual violence against women?
Look at this.
Do you see how he looks
like an actor on a stage?
Now surely it was intentional
that they put those two men who
were woken up by the noise in a
space that seems without space.
There's a surreal ungrounded
element in the film.
All right.
So they're looking for
her now, and they're
going to be [INAUDIBLE].
Can you speed up,
Kristen, so we don't
watch the whole thing
in slow motion, in full,
but we get near the end?
Is that possible to do?
So they're-- keep-- let it
speed up a little bit more.
OK.
Now we're near the ending here.
Again, see how static it
is, how that's impressive,
the building of the sets
might have been impressive.
But you see how in some
sense how uncinematic
this is in certain ways?
Seeing the camera stable in one
spot, active moving toward it,
moving in and out of
the camera's range.
This is a theatrical idea of
what the camera should do.
It's sitting in the
audience watching a set,
and in fact, you can feel the
theatrical authority here.
Watch this image now.
And then it's something
clever if you're interested
in silhouettes, creating an
image of darkness and horror,
I guess.
But you can also see
the limitations of it.
I want to show you one other
example, a more distinguished
example, an example
that does begin
to manipulate the visual
image in somewhat more
rich and significant ways,
a film even more influential
than Caligari, what
is called so often
the first science-fiction film.
It was the very first feature
length science-fiction film
in the world.
Its title is Metropolis,
directed by Fritz Lang.
And at the time,
many film scholars
claim it cost something like
five million Reichsmarks
to make.
I don't know if Reichsmarks
were the equivalent of dollars,
but let's assume they were.
In 1926, this was the
most expensive film
that had ever been
made up to that point,
and it is a measure of the
authority and the prestige
that movies had
in German society,
that so much money would
be invested in a film.
This would never have
happened in the United States.
They weren't spending that level
of money on American movies.
They didn't have to.
They couldn't.
And in some sense, it
shows you the authority
and the centrality,
but it also explains
why we had to wait before
the German film fully
discovered its cinematic
or its filmic essence.
And I'm going to
show you what I think
is the moment or one of the
moments in which this discovery
was made.
And the director we're
looking at tonight, FW Murnau,
is the director who
made this discovery
and freed the camera from
the constraints of high art,
from the constraints of the
inherited attitudes toward art
that the established culture
in Europe and especially
in Germany imposed
upon the making.
So here are a couple of
scenes from Metropolis.
Still, I think we're
not fully there yet,
but it's a significant film.
It's much admired by
certain film scholars,
although not by me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Some of you may notice
how Chaplin borrowed
from this introduction.
And you could certainly see
how this film influenced
Modern Times.
Feel a lot of Chaplin
there, I hope.
You think there's an idea
or an attitude toward what
labor means in these images?
These are the
workers of the city.
Interesting that such a
politically radical film
would be so heavily financed.
That's enough of this.
That's plenty of this, too
much of it, in fact, I think.
But can we speed up
a little, Kristen?
I think we can come to one more
image from a different part
of the film.
So I won't talk about the
plot of the film, which
is rather ridiculous I
think, although it's also
a kind of science-fiction
fantasy, a dystopian fantasy.
But there is a sequence
later in the film.
Let's go further.
So here's another image,
another moment from the film.
Visually more
exciting, but it also
shows you in some sense
how literary the film is.
And also, I want
you see it also,
because it remind you,
again, of how much Chaplin
borrowed from this movie
when he made Modern Times.
Now there are many
imaginative effects here,
but still, you see
how stable the camera
is, how stationary it is?
The kinetic power of
the camera had not yet
been discovered, not because
it was undiscoverable,
because the Americans had
discovered it a decade earlier,
but because the
power of older forms
was inhibiting the
people making the movies.
Again, in the
early days, you can
imagine that some
of these effects
would have been very
dramatic-- the falling bodies.
Still, watch what happens here.
We've turned symbolic--
Moloch, the devil,
the devil's henchman.
That's what modern
industrial society is,
a maw that will swallow us up.
You see how weird
and disturbing it is.
Thank you, Kristen.
A serious, an interesting film,
but still in certain ways,
I hope you could see
both deeply melodramatic,
and the acting styles
are very broad.
Where do they come from?
Theater.
They're theatrical acting still.
They haven't fully
adjusted despite the power
of these films, and in
intellectual and thematic ways,
they haven't fully adjusted to
the idea that they're movies.
And the man who solved this
problem or the German director
who understood more
fully than the others
what it meant to make
a movie was FW Murnau.
His dates are on the board.
You could see he died
in his early 40s.
It was a tragic death.
He was just coming into his
own as a great, great director.
He had emigrated to the United
States in the late '20s,
and the film I've listed on
the board, Sunrise in 1927,
was made in the United States.
And many people think it is the
greatest silent non-comedy made
in the United States.
It's a bit
sentimental, but there
are brilliant, brilliant,
brilliant things in it.
It's a very, very rich artifact.
And then with the famous
documentary director,
Robert Flaherty,
his last film Tabu,
which he co-directed
with Robert Flaherty,
became a tremendous success.
But he died in 1931 just
before the film was released,
just on the verge
of a kind of a claim
that perhaps no other director
in the world at that time had.
It's tragic, a tragic story.
The film in which we can see
Murnau freeing the camera
is the film called
Nosferatu made in 1922.
And some of you will
perhaps recognize it
as the origin film for a
tremendous number of horror
movies.
Many people would call it
the first horror movie.
That may be an
exaggeration or inaccurate,
but it is among--
it is certainly
the most influential and
significant early horror film.
It's based on the Dracula
story, and like Dracula itself,
it tells a very
strange sort of story
about vampires who
survived for centuries
and then come into the world,
and by their little sort
of suggestive sexual bite
in the neck of a woman,
transform the women
into vampires as well.
And it's now a kind of
commonplace established idea
that this energy, that
the kind of Gothic fantasy
that is embodied in
the story of Dracula
and in so many similar ones,
has its origins in various forms
of sexual fantasy.
And the Dracula figure, when
he kisses the woman's neck,
is symbolically engaged
in a sexual act.
And the woman's resistance
but then her transformation
into a vampire is presumably
the woman's transformation
to sexual activeness
in some way.
At least these are the kinds
of symbolic or underlying
associations that
many scholars bring
to bear when they talk
about why such stories were
so fascinating and so popular
at the end of the 19th century.
So one thing to
remember about Nosferatu
is it is an
adaptation of a novel
already very widely known.
And in fact, there were
copyright questions
about Nosferatu.
The copyright owners from
the book sued the filmmakers,
and I'm not sure
what the outcome was.
But the film did
survive in any case.
So here are a couple of scenes.
Here is the beginning
of Nosferatu.
And the subject matter seems
to me not that interesting,
but again, my view is not
necessarily the only view.
There are people who
love these films.
I don't know why they do, but
I don't want to simply impose
my view on you.
If you're interested
in this, or if you
share a love of horror
film-- one of my problems
is I don't like
horror films today,
even though they've reached
a very sophisticated level.
I think they're silly.
I don't get them.
So I'm not a good judge of
them, and my negative judgments,
take them with a grain of salt.
They're partly colored
by my own preoccupations.
There are ways I could
defend my position,
but I don't feel I should
impose my views on you.
I do think it's a silly
story, and it seems to me
that reality is complex
enough without sort
of inventing horrors
that hide underground
for thousands of years and
emerge with magical powers.
The actual horrors
of reality seem to me
sufficient and not
adequately studied.
So that's one of my objections
to these forms of fantasy.
But in any case,
that's personal.
But in any case, what you
can see in Nosferatu, even
people who are not as interested
in the subject matter,
they can see what a technically
innovative film it is.
Watch this.
Here's the beginning.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In, fact freeze it already.
Does this seem more
realistic to you?
Do you see already--
no fake sets?
We don't feel we're watching a
theatrical piece, that a camera
is filming a theater piece?
What's one of the
reasons for that?
The natural sunlight.
That's natural sunlight.
Go ahead.
The texture of his
bedding also is a factor.
And of course, the sunlight is
a crucial motif in the film,
because Dracula
lives by darkness.
And the film depends,
quite brilliantly,
on a series of juxtapositions
of light and dark,
of shadow and brightness.
Now look at this.
Freeze it, Kristen.
Freeze it for a second.
Look at this.
We're really outside
in a real world.
Look at these animals.
And you can feel the film--
at first, we're disoriented.
We don't even know why
are we looking here?
But the film's joy-- we can feel
almost the film's excitement
at showing us what the
real world looks like.
I actually find this
visually and intellectually
much more exciting than
a ridiculous set in which
a symbolically dressed monster
staggers around in a way
that no one who ever
walked the earth moved.
I find this much
more compelling.
But what was
important at the time
was how liberating it was,
because what Murnau was showing
is look what the
camera can actually do.
He's freeing the camera.
Go ahead.
OK.
That's enough of this.
Maybe I'll give you
one more quick scene.
Do we have a separate clip?
Let's go to the other clip.
Now here's something
from the end of the film.
Can you freeze it a second?
I'll sort of briefly
set the [INAUDIBLE].
This guy is Dracula's
weird assistant,
and he's escaped from jail.
I find the story idiotic,
ridiculous, totally unserious.
But look at the
realism visually here.
This is maybe the first time
that these narrow alleyways
were captured with
such precision.
It's almost as if,
at least for me,
the subject matter
is irrelevant,
and what the film is showing
about how it can render reality
is so exciting that it's as if
a new universe has opened up.
And I must admit that
even though there
were American directors who
were working with a freed camera
long before this,
no one ever used
the camera outdoors more
effectively up to this time
than Murnau.
And I'll show you a
little more of this,
even though the plot
is stupid, because you
can see how realistic and
persuasive, compelling
the visual experience is.
See the freedom of the
camera to shoot down,
how that changes around you?
The quickness of the editing.
There he is up on
top of his roof.
If you didn't know
the context, you
would see this as a form of
oppression and mistreatment.
Why are they going
after this poor guy?
And I think that is an
implication of this,
even though he's
the source of evil.
But look at the realism of this.
Look at the texture of
the bricks, the sense
you have that this is a
real place, that he really
climbed down a roof.
The movies.
If the movies
don't do this, they
have to give us a sense of that
gross reality, which the movies
have the power to do.
They have to have
very good reasons
for giving up that power.
It's a very rare film that
can really give it up.
Some animations can do it.
But even surreal films,
even films that exaggerate
or that create alternative
worlds that are not
like our real worlds today
have the kind of kinetic camera
and sense of the textured
quality of the external world
that we get in those images.
So Murnau was critical to us and
crucial to us for this reason,
and his great masterpiece
is one of the two films
that I've asked you
to watch tonight.
We're showing both Nosferatu
and The Last Laugh.
Let's do it in the order
of The Last Laugh first.
I think Nosferatu's a less
interesting film, but still
from a technical
standpoint, fascinating.
And those of you who are
interested in the history
of horror films, you
should pay attention,
because there's hardly a
frame in Nosferatu that
has not been alluded to or
echoed in later horror films.
And it is the origins
of what is now
a dominant movie genre, both a
literary and a cinematic genre.
So it's a very,
very important film.
But The Last Laugh is
a true masterpiece,
and one of the reasons I think
it's such a remarkable film
is that it's freed
in some degree
from the pretentiousness,
the surreal pretentiousness
of expressionism.
There are expressionist elements
in the film as you'll see.
Very cleverly done.
There's one immensely
grotesque and powerful moment
in which, for example,
there are a series--
we are given an image of
some gossiping women, who
are trading gossip about
the primary character.
And we'll see how interestingly
Murnau handles that sequence.
And there's an element of
distortion or grotesquery
in that.
There are also elements
in the film, moments
in the film, brilliant
moments in the film where
what is shown externally is not
what's happening externally,
but what is going on in the
mind of the primary character.
In other words, it
carries the principle
of finding ways to create
a subjective camera even
further than any
previous film had done.
There's one remarkable moment
in this film-- watch for it.
It's very astonishing-- in which
the director of photography,
Karl Freund, was asked to
sort of figure this out.
There's a moment when the
protagonist gets drunk.
He's very disappointed about
something, and he gets drunk,
and he staggers around.
And they were trying to figure
out a way of dramatizing this.
They played around
with the camera,
and they strapped the
camera to the actor's waist,
and when he staggered
around, the world you saw
was staggering too.
And it created an
immensely powerful sort
of subjective experience
for the viewer.
And there are a number of
other places in the film where
you can see that
what's being dramatized
is the inner life
of the characters.
So there are expressionist
elements in the film,
but it transcends expressionism.
It becomes a film truly about
reality without distortion,
and of course, its
basic subject is
what happens to
our old people when
they get too old to function.
This is a theme I'm
beginning to find more
and more sympathetic as I age.
But it's one of the
most powerful treatments
of this subject.
And basically, the
story is about--
as you'll see-- it's about a
porter in a hotel whose job is
to help carry baggage in.
But he's an immense
big man played
by one of the most famous
theater actors of the day, Emil
Jannings.
And at a certain point in
the film, as you'll see,
he's demoted.
He loses his job.
They take his uniform away.
His uniform is very
important to him.
And they demote him.
He has to go and work
in the men's room
as a men's room attendant.
So the film in a certain
way does several things.
First, it shows us
what Murnau himself
came to call the unchanged
camera, the free camera.
And over and over
again, you can see
how immensely innovative the
camera work in this film is.
The very opening
scene of the film
is a tour de force
you might miss
because it happened so quickly.
The camera follows a person down
an elevator, a glass elevator,
and then follows
it across the room.
The camera was actually
mounted on a bicycle
so they could move it that way.
It happens so quickly
you might not even
notice it, although filmmakers
were overwhelmed by it,
because he was doing
things with the camera
that no one else
had done before.
And you'll see other
moments in the film
where his use of the camera
is complex and innovative.
I've already talked a bit
about the themes in the film,
but let me continue this.
So I've said in a way it's
a working class tragedy.
And the very fact that
it's about an ordinary man,
but it tries to treat him
with the kind of dignity
that in the classical times
kings and high born characters
would receive is
very significant
and is a powerful aspect
of the subject matter.
What also develops
is a deep sense
of the character
of the protagonist.
The way in which his identity
is connected to his job
and how when his job, and
especially his uniform,
which is the symbol
of his authority,
is taken away, how he's
unmanned, unhousled, undone,
incapable of functioning.
So it's a very powerful,
socially aware movie.
It dramatizes character with
a kind of subtlety that's
very rare in silent film.
You really have a sense
of this man's character.
It's quite a
brilliant performance,
even though Jannings
was its theater actor,
and there is something somewhat
broad about his performance,
you can see him beginning
to adapt to the camera
and to the more nuanced
things that the camera can do.
But even the parts
of his role that
are a little sort of
exaggerated make sense
because there's something
pretentious and pompous
about his character.
One of the subtlest things
about the film, in fact,
is the way the character
has this complexity.
A character for whom
the audience's sympathy
is constantly solicited
is also imperfect,
in some ways, an annoying
old man, not a nice person,
selfish, proud of his
superiority to the other people
with whom he lives.
One of the ways you
could see this operating
is the film really operates
in two different spaces--
the space of the great
hotel and the space
where the character
played by Jannings lives.
He lives in a working class
ghetto, a working class
part of the city.
And the two environments, the
hotel and the working class
part of the city,
are juxtaposed,
and we learn about each of
them by their juxtaposition.
The working class
part of the city
is interesting for a number of
reasons, but one of the best
is the pride he
takes in his uniform.
He may be only a hotel porter,
But in his neighborhood,
he's a big man.
He's a big shot, and he's
very proud of himself.
You can even see him
boring the children
and giving them
instructions and things.
The most important
point I'm trying to make
is that he's a complex
character that we learn
this without dialogue through
the genius of silent film,
because he's both
flawed and also
an object of sympathy
and affection.
The film doesn't
simplify his character.
He's a spiky, unpleasant
man in some ways,
but we also still feel
for him and recognize
how terrible his tragedy is.
One of the most important
characteristics of the film
and the mark of what a
cinematic achievement it is
is that up until very close
to the very end of the film,
there is not a single
title card, not
a single use of words.
In other words, the film
depends upon its visual power.
And you understand even
complex things like the fact
that the character is
drunk, whether he's not
thinking straight, or that what
he's seeing is not reality,
but some distorted
version of reality.
No title cords
explain this to you.
The film has a fluency,
a visual eloquence
that's very remark-- that's
the mark of a movie maker.
But there's an
interesting tip-off here.
An interesting problem
here is presented,
and I'll end with this point.
It has to do with the
ending of the film,
and I want you to think about
this as you reflect on the film
after you've watched it.
I've described the
basic plot of the film,
and as you'll discover,
this catastrophe
that descends upon the
protagonist of the film
is reversed at the
end of the movie.
And see, he wins a lottery,
and great good fortune
descends upon him.
Don't be angry that
I've given you the plot.
You can't talk about film
seriously without doing it,
so don't be disappointed.
I won't spoil movies
by doing real spoilers.
If I think you
shouldn't know this
for the experience of the
film, I won't mention it.
But don't be annoyed
if I do this,
because I need to explain
this stuff to you.
So there's this reversal at the
end, but it's a fake reversal.
You don't really believe it.
It seems inconsistent.
Why do you think it's there?
The film was such a downer.
The original cut
was such a downer
that the people, the
producers paying for the film
said, no, no, no,
you've got to put
a happy ending on the movie.
So Murnau and his
colleagues-- it
was a collaborative process--
the screenwriter, Carl Mayer,
and the director of
photography Carl [? Freund, ?]
as well as the actors
were all collaborating
in the making of the film.
They said, OK, well,
what should we do?
So they tacked on
this happy ending.
One of the things that marks the
happy ending is a title card,
and the appearance
of the title card
is a confession
or a secret signal
to the real members of the
audience-- this film is over.
Forget this crap that's
coming at the end.
At least that's how
I want to read it.
But what you should ask yourself
as you're watching the film
are two things.
First-- not ask but
meditate on-- first
of all, this poor ending or this
ending that seems to reverse.
The reason the ending is bad
is that the whole momentum
of the film leads toward
this catastrophe at the end,
and to reverse it
by an act of fortune
like that is to deny the social
and political implications
and psychological
implications of the story.
It's a very unartistic
thing to do.
It violates the
momentum of the text,
of the trajectory
of the character.
So it's a bad thing.
But it is also an embodiment
of an enduring issue
in movie making, which is
the conflict between art
and commerce.
Movies are commercial objects.
This is hardly the only film
in the history of movies
to be distorted in this way.
And in fact, that tension
is not always negative.
Sometimes forcing directors
to sort of communicate
with their audiences is helpful.
It isn't always the case that
these commercial imperatives
are negative, although
they often are.
But this is one of those
classic instances that can you
think of other famous examples?
Orson Welles, the
American director,
was often-- suffered
tremendously
from this kind of pressure,
because his films were thought
to be unwatchable,
and one of his films
was cut against his will, and
he lost control of his films.
And he made very
many fewer films
than he might have
made had he not
been thought of as a commercial
disaster by the Hollywood money
people.
And there are many,
many other examples
of this in the
history of movies.
One could say that this is
one of the originating moments
in which the conflict between
art and commerce in the movies
is dramatized for us.
But there's
something else I want
you to think about
as well as you're
thinking about the ending.
What is the moment at
the end of the film that
really would end the film?
Because I think there is one.
It's a visually very powerful
moment, but it's so bleak.
It's so sad that you can
understand why the money
men wouldn't have liked it.
So as you're watching
the film, think about all
of these matters,
but especially think
about the way in which
Murnau discovered
more fully than any
director up to his time
what we might call the
kinetic powers of the camera.
He unchained the camera.
He [? fliberated ?] the
camera, and German film
was-- world cinema, but
German film especially,
was never the same after that.